very very welcome
hello hello
thank you for joining us hi how are you
both
wonderful how are you
i'm doing good
here i am in uh
madrid i just got back from the hall and
uh
wonderful tell us about chennai tell us
about the olympiad what all
you're doing vishy i know you're an
ambassador for fiji ambassador for the
chess world but
tell us what's what's going on in
chennai in the olympiad
look everyone's very excited the
state government the central government
the federation obviously everyone's very
excited they're all working together
preparations are
coming along quite fast
and it's nice it's the most
pleasant part of the city
along the beach road
should be relatively cool there
they found a very good venue
and
they've selected the massacre and
everything going very fast because we
had to do everything in a few months
and they're looking forward to the event
so
how many teams are how many teams are
expected uh
to uh descend upon india for the olympia
so this year it'll be 189 whoa
that's and because of that india gets to
even it out with the third team so
that's nice for us as well so we have a
third team playing
wow
and it'll make it 190. wonderful
record participation
had some nice questions prep for you
well speaking of the um chennai olympiad
um i saw in the news a few weeks back
that you were
you initiated
might have to help me out with the
wording here the the flame of the
olympic carrying of the torch yes thank
you yeah that we call it the torture
relay flame whatever
olympic flame touch relay yes um
this was a new idea they came up with to
promote the
olympiad in india
and it's it's a brilliant idea because
the prime minister started it in
new delhi
and after that it's gone to many cities
it's gone to our northernmost and
highest
uh town lay
in um
the northeast then it went to
it's been slowly winding its way through
the country it's going to go to 75
cities wow because it's the 75th
anniversary of india's independence
so to commemorate that it's going to go
to 75 cities and in each city
they have a very important function
there's a lot of press coverage so it's
a brilliant idea i think to
make sure everyone in the country knows
that the olympia is happening
well that's
certainly wonderful wonderful yeah and
well i i have way more questions
let me get one in first vichy good to
see you my friend i expected you to
still be on your running shoes but i see
that you have visited madrid
tell us this tournament came as a shock
to all of us not just because one player
ran away with it but because we saw a
lackluster performance from a few of
these players did you expect that you
yourself came back as somebody that lost
the world championship crush the
candidates did you see nepo doing the
same
um yes but he's uh over he's overdone it
a bit he's
gone and done plus five
which is ridiculous
um
and i was really shocked by fabi i think
because nepo yan was keeping the space
it put pressure on others even who had
very healthy scores i mean it's amazing
that fabio on plus three felt he had to
take so much risk
to
catch him because
for a couple of games i i felt he lost
his objectivity and um
something went wrong to fabian it's
clearly pressure which
is
not from some self-inflicted pressure
it's quite a lot of strange performances
from the others
right which which game did you feel that
five lost objectivity in
certainly the ding one i mean i would
normally expected him convert that
efficiently right though it was maybe
slightly unexpected that it became a
winning position but then uh normally
this should be well within fabi's grasp
right um
his opening choice against ricardo i
would have to agree with hikaru that
he had better options but it's this
feeling i think fabi was looking for
something where black would have
substantial winning chances
to my mind he chose something without a
lot of winning chances this open ray is
not really for that
but maybe he just thought an unbalanced
position would be what he wants against
ikaru aika so that was costly
um
and then with uh duda as well
but you know it's it's the runaway you
know once things start going wrong then
you get angry with yourself and
suddenly you have to gamble even more
and
but ian made it look very very easy so
full credit to him there were
only a few moments when he was
challenged and he
came out
he got out of it quite easily so we
shouldn't take credit away from him from
for that and tell us your thoughts about
it you're now involved with fita you are
running in the ticket of course you
can't tell us exactly what's going on
behind the scenes but your opinion will
magnus actually play and if he plays
will it be under the same circumstances
what everybody is buzzing about these
days
yes exactly
so
magnus was here yesterday in madrid and
he met
with uh
the president and uh i think also with
emil a little bit they discussed some
scenarios so for the moment i think
he's
come up with some
changes he would like to see
luckily he tweeted about it so i didn't
i don't have to worry about whether i'm
betraying some confidence he
he wants
a different format something that he
thinks
allows one chess player to show his
superiority over another chess player
quote unquote
and
[Music]
that's where it's at so he's not made a
final decision he will still revisit the
team and he's agreed to park his
demands but he's not said yes either
and that's the current status and um
obviously now
his opponent has a name and a face and a
publisher so he'll have to be consulted
as well there's some work ahead but
let's see so just to be clear with both
sides of keeping it open would this be
for the current
world championship cycle that would be
this demands would be for this one or
for the next cycle itself
i think it's for this one because he's
uh his participation is in question this
one that's true so he's he's negotiating
for that
he basically feels that um
more
you need to mix it up a bit more maybe
more blitz and rapid something like that
was along the lines of what he suggested
so um
yeah uh
we'll get to that if if i'm in office in
august then i'll also deal with it
i'll i'll [ __ ] that i'll hold that
thought till then
if i'm in office very nice
spoken like a politician a gifted
politician very very nice
and
i learned from the best jazz
but uh for you vishy you have
represented indy your entire life i
remember playing against you in fact
in i think it was dubai in 1986 so you
have been leading the indian team for
some
decades
nostalgic feelings about not playing for
india this go around especially
the olympics being hosted in india
not too much because i will be there the
whole time and i get to hang out with
everyone and i don't have to prepare for
my games so
not too bad
and
by the way this decision i made earlier
it's
part of it
uh a plan i'm not playing the world cup
anymore i'm not playing the grand swiss
anymore i'm not playing the grand prix
anymore i'm not playing the olympiads
anymore i'm playing much less and uh
so
clearly my
career is kind of transitioning okay and
um this was part of that and i didn't
feel like changing my mind just because
unexpectedly they even came to
india but uh look i'm every much every
bit
of the fan i was and i will be there all
around and uh try to enjoy the olympiad
from the other side
wonderful
um sorry now that we've got you here it
would be it would be wrong of us not to
exploit you
and turn you into a chess commentator
i'm looking at the game of richie report
versus timor
and very unexpectedly for us
the game has continued with a pawn
sacrifice g5
followed by a p sacrifice knight takes
g5
and you're just
knead your
reactions to this sacrifice
do you think it's good
my knee-jerk reaction is that it's just
wrong
[Laughter]
isn't bishop takes c4 and hit g5
just
great for black
rice
i mean what else do am i going to do
other than
any nonsense i didn't take on g5 first
because maybe you'll play rook takes g7
or g1 first right and this
look my first impression is this is
wrong
um maybe as i look at it i'll see that
white has this plan with the
rook a g1 and then queen h3 maybe rook
h5 so there are options
but i would guess that um
black is now also able to bring quite a
few pieces to defend right
well actually i would like to start with
queen f6 instead of bishop f8
yep
queen f6 because after i play rookie
seven i don't want the queen to be shut
on the other side okay and if i go to
key seven rook f8 how bad can this be
you're getting a lot of defenders
over right uh so white white still has
queen h3 and rook h5 maybe right but i
would assume that i can play
knight f8 and g6 or maybe rook f8
threatening queen f3 check
so there are quite a few options for me
i mean i'm spitballing but um
i could easily get into more specific
lines but uh
it
my first reaction is i don't believe
this exactly uh
me either i was like what the heck
is richard uh
miscalculated but
you've always been
super fast at seeing the tactics so i
thought i took the lazy man's
commentator approach i've got this sheet
i'm gonna
i'm gonna get ask him to calculate the
complications i'm gonna sit back and
applause
wow because we're talking about punish
four before the movement exactly so
that's why so your first reaction is
this should not work this is like
ridiculous
yeah
and
we will see if uh if that's the case
dorsa um alejandro
we have him here i mean come on with the
nepo game the nepo game is so fun so
cool right now send them to that one
okay put the camera on me we got bishop
to calculate this crazy position yes sir
if you could bring that game on your i
do have it on a board and we left it
around these parts with queen takes b2
so far the players have played like
engine's top choices up until this
moment i think vishy
alejandro was saying rook to d1 without
hg6 just
without hg6 exactly because why not keep
headaches and reserve exactly and that
was actually a key point that the move
h5h6
was really putting some pressure on
black
we're just going to jump
basically to the game position bishop
takes g6 vishy
f takes g6 queen e4 on the board and
once again
just your knee-jerk
impression is this
good for
who um
i want to play rook takes d6 but queen
g6 you start with queen g6 check first
yeah that's a problem if i go king g7
then you have rook b1
rook b1 yep oops and that is not going
to be good kind of crashing through
right
well hang on a second so
king g7
rook b1 let me go bishop d5
wow
cool
but
i even have rook takes b2 and knight
takes e4 so
uh what's the body count though oh well
maybe good thing now we had a body well
yeah maybe good for white actually yeah
slight edge
yes it would be six rook c2
maybe maybe it's equal for black i don't
know okay
um but if you don't have bishop d5 then
you're lost so that's the problem but uh
yeah bishop g6 and queen e4 was clever
in fact
i was checking this at uh a few moves
ago at the point when he went queen
takes b2 or right before that
we were trying to find scenarios
and bishop j6 and queen e4 we didn't
examine we kept trying to make head six
work with something or the other or
bishop a4 e8
and we were not really managing to get
this world but bishop g6 and queenie for
very decent ray and
if
what should black play
yeah i was thinking bishop f7 perhaps
yeah but then i can take on uh f7 if i
want
aha
yeah i mean just simple king f7 e6 check
exactly and now you either have to
blockade it with your king which is not
a good idea or
feels
feels like i'm on the precipice of
defeat right
yeah now
queen h4 check queen at seven check
yeah no i'm not a happy camper at all uh
not at all no bishop f7 oh for me sorry
queen e4
um yeah bishop f7
also knight f7 and b1 might be still
unpleasant
exactly
well
the desirable bishop f5 unfortunately
takes and queen d5 checks spears the
bishop if not
anything worse uh you're you're
definitely
uh not
happy there uh
this looks pretty all we have left is
this king g7 and bishop d5 i don't know
yeah this look this could be very very
frightening actually uh
your impressions of do does event
the candidates it says there were three
players coming
out as rookies uh vichy
including duda he came in with high
expectations having just won the warsaw
grand chester
uh rabbit and blitz
what do you think about duda
i think uh
duda and ferocia
um felt a lot of pressure mainly from
themselves
i think they really wanted to do well
they were very motivated but
sometimes in the candidates you also
have to see what happens after the first
few rounds you know what situation turns
up
um
especially ferocious i think
had this mix of just feeling that he
could
take a lot of liberties
and
things will work out if he just
went by willpower or something it
doesn't work like that he got punished
multiple times
and then it feeds on itself his form
dropped
and you know once it starts to go wrong
as we both know hey
you find ways of making life difficult
for yourself
rapport for me is harder to say what
he never
he never got going but i don't even know
if i really considered him one of the
favorites he's unpredictable so in both
ends you know he can have a very good
tournament or a very bad one um
fabi for me was a bigger surprise
because when he was going to plus three
you felt
um he's very much in shape but what are
you doing in someone who's plus four and
then you feel you have to take these
extra risks
um
but yes a lot of people playing there
for the first time
and alejandro any more questions for our
illustrious guests
you gave us a lot of i'm doing politics
here i'm in madrid but vichy people miss
seeing you play you mentioned you're
playing less but what are you playing
this year what are your fans looking
forward to
well i will uh right after this
tournament i'm traveling to leon so in
fact day after i'm going to leon and i'm
going to play a tournament there that's
myself the magistrate alone it's myself
girlfriend esipenko
and jaime santos latassa
um
and uh
after that i will uh visit beale
and uh i don't know playing but i'll
visit dale and then go on to dortmund
where i go for my annual no castling
tournament
no castle
i expect to play something later this
year but not yet announced and so on
uh how is it vishy for you when you
have an old rival like boris galfand i
mean and you see one another and you go
i remember when you were a young boy
when when did we first play i mean that
was a great world championship match
that you played with boris and i
especially remember your quote
i won because i won
[Laughter]
well boris
boris's presence automatically means i
am the
only the second oldest participant after
a very long time which is wonderful
right that's wonderful
and this uh
i just saw that people who played with
me in the juniors in oakham
have now won the world senior steam
championship
it's weird out there yes you you got
there before but you know it's weird
still when you go through this
and but it's nice yes um
with boris and me uh we go back such a
long way
and uh it'll be nice that he's also
competing and in fact it's almost a
senior versus junior's event because the
other two uh maybe just 20 each or 19
each or something kids kids oh
yeah
and the two of us i thought they so
normally the way they split the pairing
is they have two people who cannot be
paired with each other
and then they draw from the remaining
two numbers right so
let's say i couldn't play girlfriend
then i could draw from one of the other
two
um
that would be obvious by age but it's
not the case by rating so
from
there in leon man
we're gonna watch out there but
it's gonna be a great event i always
loved this battle of generations from
these talents that you've mentioned you
have so many in india of course we have
hazy panko coming up he's a strong 2700
but from the indian players
we you have so much talent you got to
pick one this is the one that you feel
is going to be head and shoulders over
the others five years from now who is it
um
i want to say two names but uh you're
really putting me on a spot okay i'll go
with uh
i'll go with pragmata
what about the women
um women
why shelley is doing very well right now
and then i think we have a slight gap
amongst the
juniors so
we need to work a bit harder to have
some
top talents there
there are two girls there's girl divya
deshmook and
vantik agarwal
both still juniors but
some hope
you know some talent there
and
i but i think you know our bench is much
stronger and uh
on the male side in juniors there i can
easily give you six names
who are very very strong we have now two
of them are in the top 50 and pragnanda
is just a little bit behind
so there's
quite a few of them
who are just very strong and very
competitive
um
but in the girls yeah we still have to
work a bit
all right
vishy uh we are on behalf of the whole
panel we really want to thank you for
taking time out of your day to join us
it was really great pleasure
and to wish you and india
the greatest of successes for the
upcoming olympiad it was it will be an
event the whole world will be watching
thank you yes uh
of course worth knowing that the
the dream team is from the us again
right the dream team
yeah yeah
30 years later and you guys have a dream
team again it's just in chess this time
so
but uh
you know it's great day you're coming
full strength and it should be a great
event i
can i push you a little bit to come and
visit but
you can ask me anything it was funny
that you should say that because our
friend eric hansen he's like he's with
the canadian team he said come on come
on chennai is going to be great it's
going to be great
but i i for one seriously i
i have never visited india uh
and uh
it's a great excuse for anybody who
loves chas to go to india and see all
the great players and i know your being
there and your welcoming presence
uh will uh inspire
many many to visit
i'll take you to some nice places i'll
throw that one in
thank you very much are you coming yes i
am going to be the uh coach for the
olympic team for the women so i'll
definitely see you there fantastic
good
all right
thank you again uh vishy uh always a
pleasure
yeah thanks cheers
wow uh